creativity is using what you have to
create something new
and beautiful a combination of multiple
people coming up with
new ideas that other people can then
feed off and expand upon
the sound was just something i just
gravitated towards
plus i like knobs
you know ever since the dawn of sound on
movies
it's been dialogue that has really
helped to
you know elevate movie making into a
supreme art form for storytelling
sound can work in mercurial ways that
picture khan's
got this wonderful way of sneaking in
through the back door and
people don't really understand they're
being told it's magic stuff
with seoul we had to create all these
different worlds you had the great
beyond
and you had new york city and then you
had the astral plane
joe is like in his own world but he's so
used to new york city that none of that
phases him
one of the interesting things that
happened with mank in terms of that is
that
i think that there had been this sense
of the trajectory of
sound and film the the spatialization of
sounds
to the left and right and above and
behind us all the things that we can do
now
david didn't want to do he wanted to say
yeah that's great for a modern film but
i want to
i want to take us back i really did love
little subtle stuff that i took time to
play with like in the cabin
it's not usually stuff i want to bring
people's attention to
but it was fun to work on it's kind of
this little musical element and i
and i think i hope subliminally it
brings people into the
into the atmosphere with some kind of
emotional color the main character
relies a lot
on sound and eventually he gets into a
situation where he cannot
rely on that anymore i'm really proud
that this film is nominated for sound
because i think it's it's a very silent
field we didn't get like
millions of dollars to do the sound
but the way we work together is
something i'm really proud of the
marriage of those ideas
and how the story is told and the script
and the photography and everything comes
together i think that's why it can
become so powerful
when we're looking at the scene we're
still building in terms of frequencies
choosing different elements that are
doing different parts of a job just like
you would in music you're still
choosing something that's got rhythm or
something that's got
something defined in the top there are
very few jobs you get to do in movies
where you have to sit with the filmmaker
in order for them to hear what we hear
they have to sit next to us
to see the movie through their eyes and
and experience in its absolute final
form and just put that little sprinkle
on top
my thoughts about the future of sound in
film is
as long as we want humans to tell
stories
the human voice will always need to be
recorded you know i don't think it
matters what
technological advances that we make
sound is a very technology driven
industry and we're always waiting for
the next thing to come out
i think this last year of pandemic and
all that sort of stuff has
has shifted our focus so much more now
at home and make that still feel
big like the theater is a real challenge
i really hope that the future
of sound for movies is people seeing and
hearing movies back in
theaters the visceral experience you get
when you get to hear
any film the way we get to hear it is so
above and beyond
whatever you could do at home getting
back to theaters and really immersing
yourself
is something that i really hope that is
what happens in the very near future